a lot of special effects come into play
when filming a movie like descendants -
and if you're like us you want to know
what things looks like before and after
technology kicked in watch until the
guns for a special sneak peek of
descendants under the sea this bonus
entry will blow your minds first time
with the things don't forget to hit that
subscribe button and give this video a
big thumbs up now let's find out with
the descendants - movie looks like
before and after the special effects
wicked apples without special effects
many of our favorite - students - scenes
wouldn't have been possible with this in
mind we've tracked down some of this
film's most epic scenes and we're going
to give you a closer look the second
dissonance movie starts with a bang and
it's all thanks to one of our faves
songs ways to be wicked the movie begins
with mal Edie and Carlos and Jay
standing around the smoking cauldron
they're throwing red apples into its
bubbling Center and mal is enchanting
the fruits with evil incantations thanks
to the mini special effects in the shot
the scene actually comes off as scary
but this wouldn't have been possible
without camera tricks and a CGI while it
may appear that the crew is standing
under a canopy of gorgeous stars they're
actually acting in front of a green
screen and despite the fact that the
cauldron is bubbling with green smolder
our four friends are merely playing with
cold water without today's technology
this scene wouldn't have been possible
in the end we're happy it came to life
after all it is the opening scene of the
movie talking dog when you think about
it there'd be nothing better than being
able to understand what your furry
little friends is feeling sadly animals
don't have the same vocal cords as we do
as many of you surely know no one loves
their pop more than Carlos from
descendants on more than one account
carlos has voiced his love for dude the
dog he just never thought he'd voice it
back well in these students - we finally
got the chance to see dude the dog in
action the canine was voiced by actor
Bobby Moynihan who is a proud member of
the Saturday Night Live Crew Carlos's
dog is granted the ability to speak
after eating a magical treat from mouths
purse afterward it's almost as though
his lips have a mind of their own while
you're at it
my thought well that's sort of the case
when you think about it after all CGI X
firts did off to the dogs lip movements
to insert Bobby's voice it's funny to
think that mal and Carlos had to pretend
to talk to a dog for the scene to work
out regardless everyone did a mighty
fine job mal on a motorcycle Mao might
be the daughter of an evil villain but
she isn't as rotten as her reputation
makes her out to be after falling in
love with Ben from Arden Prep Mao
decides to pursue a good girl look but
ends up losing herself in the process
despite wanting to be a better person
mal is prone to using magic whenever it
serves her and this doesn't exactly fly
with her boyfriends Ben after finding
out that mal is still using her spell
book the young couple gets into a fight
the lover's quarrel causes Mau to want
to go back to her roots so that's
exactly what the blonde teenager does to
get back to the Isle of the Lost
Mao gets on the back of her new
motorcycle and speeds off across the
ocean but wait how on earth could she do
that
well this act is something only a real
wizard or a gifted CGI artist could
master while it may look like mal is
doing the impossible she's just sitting
on her bike in front of a green screen
if there's one thing that's for sure
it's that actress Karen dub must have
laughed after seeing the scenes final
product magical car ride there's nothing
worse than finding out that someone you
care about has run away with this in
mind it isn't surprising to learn that
Evie Carlos J and been chosen to loss to
retrieve mal much like mal her evil
friends had the thought to travel over
the ocean using a magic spell
they created an enchanted bridge and
then drove it over with their car
despite wanting to keep a low profile
the Friends of means of transportation
wasn't exactly the most low-key option
regardless they managed to enter their
home town without arising too much
suspicion so by now you're probably
asking yourself how does they film that
bride seem and the answer is quite
simple and they didn't instead Carlos
Evie Ben and Jay all got into a car and
the special effects did the rest
afterward it was just a matter of
getting out of the car to make the scene
look believable the golden bridges look
was achieved by using computer software
but we have to admit that it tied the
scene together beautifully
boat scenes it takes a lot of work to
create a massive set like the one we see
in descendants - yeah
but luckily this production has plenty
of talented professionals who dedicate
their time to making the sets look
believable and gorgeous halfway through
descendants - we get introduced to uma
and her ship which is floating in the
sea where it should be however it isn't
exactly how things went down during the
filming process the boat scene was
actually filmed indoors however it
received its outdoor makeover with the
help of talented CGI artists the
original set was filled with
green-screen tarps which allowed artists
to fill in the blanks online thanks to
these special effects
uma shep looks like it's floating in the
ocean in front of snowy mountains are
you shocked to find out that every
single Isle of the Lost scene is
actually filmed indoors because we sure
were but hey we can't deny that it makes
a lot of sense colorful slingshots now
might have told Ben to leave her alone
but she never stopped loving him so when
Emma kidnapped him she did everything
she could to get him back the problem
was to get Ben back mal had to hand over
the fairy godmothers wand to the evil
mastermind so naturally she chose to
create a fake replica of the wand and
traded it for her boyfriend's life uma
who stayed true to her word handed Ben
back to his friends once the wand was in
her hand
sadly she soon realized that Malhotra
too escaped a vicious fight mal and her
friends quickly began to retreat and
luckily Carlos was by their side and
ready for action
who Ella's son took out his slingshot
and started throwing poof's of colour
into the boat
this stopped the villains from being
able to see allowing the team to run
away while the bursts of color seemed
all too real they're the opposite of
that instead
Emma's crew had to pretend to be
burdened by the smoke and the rest was
left to special effects so not only did
Carlos pretend to shoot the Pirates with
a slingshot but the Pirates also
pretended to be affected by his actions
if this surprises you wait until you see
the bonus entry at the end of this video
Pumas transformation the cotillion was
supposed to be a fun and memorable event
however the only person who seemed to be
having a good time was luma after using
her powers to control Ben Ouma attended
the dance with him to make mal angry
unfortunately for Ouma now quickly
realize that Ben wasn't himself and she
kissed him to get rid of the spell after
it became clear that Emma was up to no
good she climbed the ship's edge and
jumped into the ocean but being Ursula's
daughter and all she transforms into a
sea witch instead a paddling around as a
human would to achieve this scene Ouma
was made to jump into a pool of water
surrounded by green screens
this gave the production more than
enough footage to alter after the night
sky was added to the shot boom as lexer
transforms into tentacles
all in all who is transformation was
beyond shocking but we'd be lying if we
said we didn't love it
Mouse transformation being the daughter
of Maleficent can give you a lot of
special perks however having this
Enchantress as a mother does have a
handful of downfalls as well if there's
one thing we all know about mal is that
she isn't one to back down from a fight
so when Numa transformed her into her
true self now decided to do the same
the young villains eyes began to turn
green before a cloud of purple smoke
started to wrap around her body despite
knowing what was coming Ben seemed
totally shocked about the fact that mal
was turning into a big purple dragon as
soon as she emerged mal flew into the
sky and began attacking Ouma with fire
this is around the time that Ben jumped
into the water to separate the two women
to master the scene the descendants two
crew were made to look up to the ceiling
with terrified looks on their face by
following the mark the cast made way for
the perfect template for sea
I artists to follow the scene ended with
Ben jumping into the pool with uma and
pretending that mal was flying above
them once again this scene wouldn't have
been possible without the use of green
screens and computer screens the fights
it goes without saying that fighting is
never the answer
with us in mind then jumped into the
ocean to stop his girlfriends from
killing her enemy despite being a
powerful sea witch Huma is no match for
a fiery dragon while it's pretty obvious
that these two villains don't like each
other now could get expelled for her
crimes and end up losing everything
she's worked so hard to gain a lot of
CGI was needed to achieve this team
after all the descendants - crew was
simply standing on the set of a boat and
pretending that magical beams were
fighting around them Indian artists had
to capture the night sky Mao's flames
and umas tentacles all in one which was
no easy feat but once again these
graphics were strewn together so
perfectly that the scene appears to be
unfolding before our eyes who must
promise just when we thought that Emma
would leave our favorite villains alone
we found out that she has other plans in
mind after escaping her death Huma
returns to the Isle of the Lost but
instead of being defeated
Ursula's daughter has a strange smile on
her face in this scene we see uma
swimming through the ocean her large
tentacles are still attached to her body
proving that she has little interest in
returning to her human state right
before reaching dry land
uma turns around to face the camera and
tells us that her story is not over this
terrifying scene might look super real
but once again it's nothing more than
actress China and MacLean swimming in
the pool directors and producers were
impressed by how quickly tried and
nailed her role the young actress was
amongst hundreds who auditioned for it
but after her audition is became
painfully evident that she was the only
one for the job now here's the moment
you've all been waiting for
the under-the-sea bonus entry bonus
entry stronger as many of you already
know descendants three will be coming
out on the Disney Channel in 2019 to
tide us over until then though Disney
released and under the sea's short film
in September of 2018 and it's amazing
one of the most memorable scenes is
definitely the stronger music video
which is jam-packed with awesome dance
moves and special effects since this
song is mostly filmed underwater both
uma and
now had to film their scenes in a huge
pool on top of all that now had to
pretend to see Emma's face everywhere
she looked this is due to Emma having a
handful of new powers that only manifest
themselves while under the sea once
outside of the pool Loula still had to
get her feet wet the crew built a dance
script that was only 20 feet by 20 feet
they filled it with water and made the
dancers kick and splash around filming
this short film was not an easy thing to
do especially since it was mainly filmed
in a pool with the help of green screens
and computer-generated imagery The
Descendants cast was able to capture
their vision so were you a fan of the
short film if so tell us what your
favorite part was in the comments and
that's a wrap thanks for watching and
see you next time on the things
[Music]